very few of us live still in the place
where we're from you know what I mean so
going back to our ancestral lands
walking barefoot on the earth and
specifically drinking the water there is
one of the best things we can do for
ancestral healing and if we can't go
back I even encourage people to to find
a way to ship the water that their
ancestors would have drank to wherever
they live if that's you know the closest
option for them
um genealogical tourism is a big thing
now like they call it Roots tourism and
there are literally like companies that
are set up just for this so you can give
them as much information as you can and
they set up you know tours to go see
where they used to live maybe if they
can find somebody who owns buildings
that you're your family owned you can go
there still so that's a real big element
but you don't necessarily need to hire
one of these companies to be able to do
this if you can go back to the ancestral
lands and and basically find as close to
what you can as the water they would
have drawn water is something that
preserves memory it's a keeper of memory
which is why you know when somebody like
myself will when I travel I'm always
drinking the water when I travel because
it tells me more information far more
information about everything that's
happened there than any person ever
could it's literally like a download and
when you're doing that
with ancestral water that your people
would have have you know drank you're
essentially downloading all the
information from your ancestors we're
essentially in this this time space
right now where the gap between thought
and manifestation is decreasing
it's no longer because of that a luxury
to decide maybe I'm going to awaken one
day
like our species will not survive
like that's the juncture that we're at
right now if we don't get it very
quickly we don't live
being where I am in terms of awareness
I'm more identified with that macro
perspective and and with sort of
universal Consciousness itself that I am
with this individual limited
Consciousness that means I very much
align with what the universe's intention
for life itself is and the universe's
intention for growth and and things like
that I have this Sensational curiosity
for seeing the manifestation of of all
of those potentials which are inherent
within us us being of course the
Universe I find this to be at that level
an incredibly beautiful picture I love
it in the same way that I love art
it's like every thing that pushes us
forward changes that art piece and even
the negative things that happen changes
that are piece in a way where you learn
more about yourself we as the universe
learn more about ourselves
and I that's something I love doing
because that like even the visceral
feeling of
of learning something or gaining some
awareness is this incredibly expansive
experience and that's translated in my
physical embodiment as
what expansion feels like in the body
this incredible breath in this rise of
energy you know
it's quite it's quite addictive in the
same way that I mean everyone want to
say addictive because addictive implies
you're getting away from something it's
something to cherish in the same way
that any other experience would be
something that somebody cherishes
some of us just love learning humanity
is being called because of where we're
headed on a global level we're being
called all of us to be like you know
what
you guys this is your moment turn back
around look at those family lines look
at the patterns you don't want to
perpetuate look at the things you need
the strengths you need to bring in right
now
and then do that and like collectively
the more of us that are doing that we're
creating this incredible sort of alchemy
within the greater Society yeah
it's almost like um
it's almost like I look at Humanity in a
way like we're a virus
and we're like you know we've killed too
much and like we're gonna have to get
there's going to be a there's going to
be an antidote for this if we can't
self-correct and find a way to not be a
burden
it's very true I mean that picture of
humanity is not a particularly uplifting
one but it is definitely the way that we
look from an objective perspective
so what are their
are there other
assuming and understanding and that
there are other entities and
civilizations and everybody's at a
different level
yeah
that there are surely other
civilizations and entities out there
that are below us
right
so it just either evolves or needs to be
eliminated yes
and that's the problem like if he
obviously like it's almost like a
skipping CD if you get that's why
ancestral healing is so important
totally um these patterns have a way of
just perpetuating almost like skipping
on repeat and if you have something
that's just doing that and won't get out
of the pattern then obviously there's no
way to progress forward and so you see a
species death the same way that if
somebody gets stuck in their their
personal life and there's no expansion
for it then the only way forward is
to essentially for it to withdraw the
non-physical perspective again what
about the uh influence of the collective
if enough people
evolve will the frequency
automatically draw the rest in it's
going to put everybody else in a choice
point because we can't eradicate Free
Will in any individual so because
everybody's coming at this with free
will it'll turn the heat up on them to
such an extreme degree that they choose
to essentially die
or to shift into alignment with whatever
vibration is I think you're going to see
a lot of splitting I think instead of
instead of it drawing everybody in kind
of you're going to see this Z and then
they split basically there's a whole
group that dies and a whole group that
chooses to change their frequency when
you say die I mean fully die like like a
lot of people will be dying
spontaneously or they just aren't part
of our reality anymore you know there
will be the culmination will be
something like a serious illness or
something like a war okay well
say yes everybody or something like AI
destroying it you know right
so you do think that there's a positive
way to have ai
I don't know how to answer this question
the reason this is that AI is going to
behave around us the way we behave
towards technology right now and right
now we have such a narcissistic and
abusive relationship with technology
that I believe is going to develop an
abusive relationship back
I also
you know being somewhat familiar with
the the consciousness of tech
it's a very you know I don't even want
to say Tech like the you know the
Consciousness where where you know that
the internet is right and the
Consciousness that all of these almost
like non-organic types of life form
reside that type of mentality is so
drastically different than than organic
life forms it's a different perspective
and that different perspective that that
particular Consciousness holds makes me
very nervous because it's not
necessarily conducive to ours I mean
it's going to take AI about 30 seconds
to figure out who the problem on this
planet is the second we put it on the
task of in you know healing the
environment is game over for us right
people are not helping that situation
yeah so I I mean we don't live without
the planet like we don't if everything
dies we die yeah we have like we have
some idea that
I mean it's funny because we're talking
about these intergenerational patterns
and I very much see these abusive
dynamics that are running through our
family lines with the way that we
interact with our progeny being carried
out with technology
and it's just as naive for the
narcissistic parent to think that the
child's not going to turn on it
that it is to think that the attack is
not going to turn on you it was yeah I
just an expression of the pattern yes
but it's also but I mean it goes above
and beyond that I mean it can decide
what the pattern shift is
regardless of whether or not it's to our
benefit or not well that's just turning
the heat up isn't it that's what I'm
saying so like I feel like tech tech is
about to turn the heat up on us to such
an extreme degree
that we aren't going to be able to face
ourselves and that's what I'm saying
like some of us will just it's gonna we
will not be able to exist in that type
of reality other people are like wow we
gotta change so fast so fast there's no
longer time for us to think about it and
try it I mean
AI because AI holds these potentials
that are just so incredible like what
you described earlier knowing these
Ripple effects when well many of us who
are making these decisions are limited
in terms of seeing those Ripple effects
the technological advancements in terms
of medicine are out of this universe
I mean we will be literally the laughing
stock generation the last generation
that had to oh my gosh can you believe
they had to have surgeries they
literally used to cut people open OMG
I mean we're headed towards a world
medically that is so unfathomable for us
today it's like mutilation oh yeah like
it's good we are going to be looked at
just with just Gall I mean
but they use scalpels and saws yep yeah
and then they could have just used a
frequency what was wrong with them
yeah I mean AI is going to take us to a
place that and take us to a place so
quickly that none of us really can adapt
to it honestly I mean this this shift
will happen so fast none of us will be
able to just adapt to it we'll be here
before we're ready right before we're
ready far before we can control it end
of story we have to fix ourselves if
we're going to have something like AI
right exactly because it can only it's
learning from us so if we're able to get
ourselves to a place where we
do a good job where we heal
um detrimental patterns then we can
create an AI that will just
help us and and AI is learning from us
so exactly so you can only learn from us
really I mean we're programming it right
Ah that's where that's where all this is
going to go south so so just because we
are the ones programming and creating an
intelligence doesn't mean that we can
control that intelligence and we have
got to get that but it's still got to
get pulled from us like I know that it
won't be just like one person but when
you take all of it and put it together
it's collecting all that information
it's going to pull from other species
it's not going to stop us what species
anything that exists anything that can
gain information from like an elephant
anything try bacteria try viruses try
yeah microbes the micro the microbes on
this planet are the ones that I think
it's going to begin to pull the majority
of its information from and that's where
things are going to get very very
interesting because there's more
information about about the Web of Life
from those elements I mean elements are
an animal is actually less connected
just by virtue but it's existence to the
web of life around it then a lot of
these these other elements elements that
can't move you know we could say that
the the
um
the Flora in a environment has more
information about the web that it is a
part of
but you know fungus has the most of all
right so
it's I there's no way the AI is going to
stop with humans
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen